the Joe Rogan experience do you ever do
anything like isolation tank you ever do
that I've always wanted to what happen
here if you want to do it yeah I do I've
always wanted to do that um I do I want
to kind of go back and say like I don't
want to disparage therapy I think it
does help a lot of people
it definitely has helped me I think
therapy is like comedy there's good
therapy yeah and there's terrible yeah
yeah yeah and and by the way certain
personality types really are kind of
untreatable so if you have like
narcissistic personality disorder
my therapist like the dirty secret is
will kind of like pass them off to
someone else or something because it
once you realize somebody can't see it
they're wrong they they won't really
well I talked to therapists that about
that and they said some therapy doesn't
work because all these people are really
there for us to talk about themselves
yeah yeah yeah my therapist has kind of
calls me out on [ __ ] oh so I like her my
friends who have overheard overheard us
because we FaceTime she because she's
holdover from the East Coast
she they're like it sounds like she's
your friend and she's being kind of like
hard on you but I I need that I need
somebody who's gonna I don't necessarily
always it was interesting I just learned
this past week that when you've had
trauma one of the kind of byproducts is
that not only do you not trust people
but you don't trust yourself and I was
like oh you put yourself in a bad
situation right so you don't trust her
often like your reaction to it so my
reaction to what happened to me was very
I mean yes I was young and I can forgive
myself for that but it was - I was like
hyper sexual after that you know I I and
then I I recently last week at this
moment where I was like God all the like
men that just didn't deserve me and this
is one of the I mean I really was like I
felt like I was revirginized or
something I don't know what happened but
I suddenly was like wow I I don't I
suddenly have self-worth well this is
one of the you know where I'm squishy
I'm squishy on a lot of things
and I think feminism is really important
and to like [ __ ] on it is there women
who died and got jailed for like the
right to vote so that doesn't sit well
with me but the some of the excesses of
feminism and of the in particular like
sexual liberation is that I was told sex
is empowering and it's not [ __ ]
empowering if you're not empowered
already like in my experience you were
told sex is empowering well it's kind of
the messaging is like you know women
gonna have sex too and just like it's
it's like it's an empowering name more
of an anti shame thing because like
whether it's shamed further they're sad
yeah and I think that's why I think that
I understand it I understand why that
would be the but I feel like what got
lost is that sex is very intimate and
for years there's like intimacy is so
creepy I just I didn't make like eye
contact no no we're not doing that
that's not happening and it's I do yeah
thank you yeah yeah the back we we I
just didn't have that I I don't know I
just I I missed the memo that it should
be something I was taught that it was
you know like to kind of with hold
because then a man won't respect you
which feels a little bit transactional
so there's that messaging and then
there's messaging of like free the
nipple and be empowered and like you can
have sex with whoever you want but if
you have trauma and you're not really
great on the self-esteem Department and
then you start trying to sleep your way
to empowerment it's only going to create
in my experience for me it created a lot
more shame and a vicious cycle that was
like very connected to addiction for me
to sleeping your way to empowerment is a
funny concept well suck and [ __ ] your
way in life
I mean I'm not gonna throw the baby out
with the bathwater and I know I can
already I can you know the problem with
my brain is that I can I'm always like
contradicting myself so I can that's
because life is complicated yeah and
it's not it's not binary like sex is
good sex is bad like there's different
situations where it's good and different
situation where it's terrible for you
yeah and it's just the whole weird
writing for Playboy and so to ask me us
when I started writing I always wrote I
wrote that piece Bill Cosby rape me kind
of that was a great title thank you and
then I ended up Twitter was really how I
got every connection in the writing
world I started somebody hooked me up
with an editor from Playboy and there
was this piece going around that was
like why I don't suck dick and I'm like
well someone needs to stick up for
sucking dick and that person needs to be
me
and so I pitched to playboy like in
defense of of why I love giving [ __ ]
basically and I didn't know again cuz
I'm like a child of the 90s he was just
high I didn't get the memo that now a
lot of that is seen as like
internalizing the patriarchy like
literally not eating [ __ ] second but
how's that work
oh that's okay but oh it's only okay
dick is internalized well taken into
your body well no just some some went
the whole point of like not why I don't
suck dick is that it's like it's a
degrading experience which it can feel
that way and I was saying thing can feel
pretty special and it's not it's not a
it's not this or that you know like
sexuality is so [ __ ] complicated
that's why I loved writing for Playboy
because it is everything it is shame and
fear and intimacy and love and passion
and all of it like it all happens in sex
and in those messy relationships
[Applause]